[Music]
why should fans be psyched about
this season what's going to make a
difference this season we're calling it
no risk no reward and we have twists
that we have never done before starting
with the premiere and i'm going to
present
an offer that he or she
cannot refuse i mean they can refuse but
hey
if you don't want to win then don't take
risks and don't come into the house
94 cameras and 113 microphones capture
the players every move in the redesigned
beach club themed house
complete with underwater ship and shore
themed bedrooms
chage lounge chairs in the bathroom and
an all new indoor gym
premiere night uh the house guests are
gonna be surprised to learn
that they're gonna be playing in teams
at the start of the summer
there's going to be four teams two men
to women
and then we'll see what happens from
there house guests begin their quest for
the 500 000
grand prize wednesday on cbs one thing
that will never change
the showmances there's inevitably going
to be a relationship in this house right
three months there's people mostly
single um
you know if something's going to happen
we don't advertise big brother as being
like a romance fine love show
but we have more successful marriages
that come out of this
than the bachelor you know just a couple
of weeks ago
last year's two all-stars got engaged